from working in the dining hall to
crafting lattes at a coffee shop it's
not unusual for college students to hold
down jobs as they pursue their education
but for one master's degree candidate in
the state of Virginia that other job is
not like the others Scott McFarland has
his story
Don Beyer carries his textbook on the
quad and even Sports a traditional
College sweater the education is more
important although I am striving for the
degree he's not the age of your typical
student at George Mason University in
Fairfax Virginia I hope in three years
perhaps to have a masters in in machine
learning subset of computer science and
then we'll see where it goes from there
considering what he does for a living
he's not a typical student at all the 72
year old buyer goes by another title
congressman who now spends free pockets
of time in the capital cramming for
calculus tests and we're just trying to
make it happen as quickly as we can
juggling his day job with his pursuit of
a degree in machine learning how do you
balance that how do you get a college
work done I have to get up earlier and
go to bed later I tends to consume lots
of Saturday mornings and Sunday evenings
buyers as he recognized Congress is
about to be called on to create the laws
that govern the emerging and for some
frightening artificial intelligence
technology in which machines and
computer systems perform tasks normally
requiring human intelligence although
I'm much more excited than concerned but
it's naive not to be concerned and this
economist and one time member of the
House science committee says he decided
to get a degree so that he'd actually
understand it with the explosive chat
GPT and gpd4 this is very much a topical
thing Washington has already been
grappling with artificial intelligence
dealing with a sea of new proposed
legislation one piece would restrict the
use of AI and nuclear facilities another
would restrict its use in campaign ads
how many numbers are there between 100
and 999 that have no repeated digits
meanwhile college courses in machine
learning and advanced math are
burgeoning at colleges Nationwide math
125 is required for the degree that I am
taking which is cyber security as for
the senior student at George Mason
University he's a very good student he's
very studious he makes sure that he gets
his stuff done he's pursuing his own
version of advanced intelligence for CBS
Saturday morning Scott McFarland Fairfax
Virginia
good for him that's how you learn yeah
if you're gonna if you're gonna
legislate about this you better know
about it you sometimes see these
Congressional hearings on Tech and you
wish our Representatives knew a little
bit more about the topic and to see him
pursue this is uh promising maybe he's
going to start a trend perhaps it would
be nice